We would now like to consider
a system of particles.
And let's draw them as 1, 2, 3.
And let's refer to this one
as the j particle of mass mj.
And these particles,
system of particles
is in a gravitational field.
And I would like to consider
the torque about some point
s for this system of particles.
And in particular,
I'd like to know
how do I treat the gravitational
force that's acting on all
of these individual particles.
Well, the way we'll
analyze this is
recall that the definition
of torque about some point.
Now we have n particles
labeled by index j.
It's a vector from
the place we're
calculating the torque to where
the j-th particle is located.
So we draw that vector rsj.
And we cross that
with the force that's
acting on the j-th
particle, which in this case
is the gravitational force mjg.
And this is the torque about s,
and it's this complicated sum.
But the sum will simplify
in the following way.
Let's just write out
a couple of terms
to see what it
actually looks like.
So we have rs1 cross
m1g plus rs2 cross m2g.
And we just keep on
going for the n terms.
Now quantity m1 is the scalar
units of kilograms in SI units.
But the cross product is between
this vector and that vector.
So I can actually rewrite
this as m1 rs1 cross g
plus m2 rs2 cross g, et cetera.
And you see that the
g term is the same
for every single object.
So I can write this sum-- j
goes from 1 to n as mj rsj
and pull the g out of the
sum, because every term has
the same g in the cross product.
Now let's focus on the
meaning of this sum,
where we're weighting
position by mass.
Recall that if you have the
center of mass of an object,
and we wanted to
find out where is
the location of the center of
mass with respect to point s,
then we can calculate this
vector rs cm by our definition
that the location of the center
of mass with respect to s
is given by the sum j goes
from 1 to n of mj rsj.
And we divide that
by the total mass mj.
We'll denote this term by
m total for the total mass.
So what we see here is
the total mass times
Rscm is equal to
exactly the sum that we
have in that expression mj rsj.
That's precisely that term.
And so we can conclude that the
torque about the center of mass
is m total Rscm cross g.
Now remember again
m total is a scalar.
The cross product is
between these two vectors.
And so finally, we write
this as Rscm cross m total g.
And this is how we apply
the gravitational force
to a system of particles.
Now what does that mean?
Well, that's just denote
our system like this,
and let's say here is
the center of mass,
and here's the point s.
So what we need to do is we
need to draw the vector Rscm,
and apply all the gravitational
force at the center of mass.
And then our torque
about s is the vector Rs
to where the force is
acting cross m total g.
So in conclusion, when you
have a rigid body or a system
of particles, and
you want to calculate
the torque due to a uniform
gravitational field,
then we place-- the total
gravitational force is
acting at the center of mass.
And that gives us
the torque about s
to the individual
torques of the system
of the gravitational
force about s.
All the force is placed
at the center of mass.